und jetzt sind wir gespannt was der
Bundeskanzler dazu
sagt Frau Präsidentin meine Damen und
Herren Kollegen eva schppessi hat es uns
eben gesagt wer schweigt macht sich
mitschuldig die
Gedenkveranstaltung sie hat uns alle
nachdrücklich
beeindruckt aber sie hat uns auch ein
Auftrag mitgegeben dass wir jetzt nicht
schweigen wenn in diesem Land
Konferenzen stattfinden in Landhäusern
woerüber beraten wird wie ein Teil der
Bevölkerung aus diesem Land
herausgebracht werden kann Remigration
als Stichwort das erinnert an die
dunkelsten Zeiten der deutschen
Geschichte und das ist nicht nur ein
Wort wie dann einige verharenlosen
versuchen sich das zurechtzulegen was
dort von ihnen selber diskutiert und
gesagt wird und von ihren Mitarbeitern
mitgeplant wird wir wissen dass es in
Landtagen jetzt von der AFD beantragt
wird und deshalb bin ich sehr froh
darüber dass so viele Bürgerin und
Bürger über alle Parteigrenzen hinweg
auch solche die sich überhaupt nicht
parteipolitisch verorden gemeinsam in
Deutschlands Straßen zusammenkommen in
Kundgebung und für die Demokratie für
unser Grundgesetz und gegen das
Vergessen
demonstrieren und das ist mir an dieser
Stelle auch ganz wichtig weil mir immer
wieder und viel zu oft jetzt Bürgerin
und Bürger unseres Landes
Staatsangehörige Frauen und Männer die
seit Jahrzehnten hier leben die ihren
Kinder hier groß geworden sind erzählen
dass sie Angst haben ob sie gemeint sind
ob sie jetzt das Land lassen müssen und
deshalb finde ich braucht es an dieser
Stelle auch ein ganz klares Bekenntnis
von uns allen wir stehen vor diesen
Bürgern und Bürgern sie müssen sich
nicht fürchten die Demokratie beschützt
uns wie Eva schess es heute gesagt
hat ich glaube D es deshalb auch wichtig
ist dass wir sind im Umgang miteinander
und dass
wir lachen Sie über sich selber Anstand
ist ja jetzt nicht das
kernkompetenzanliegen der
AFD sondern es geht doch darum dass wir
auch dann klar machen worum es hier geht
um rechtsextreme Ansichten die wir nicht
akzeptieren können und deshalb finde ich
es immer immer Herr MZ ein kleines Karo
wenn in dieser Situation dann jeweils
auf den anderen gezeigt wird was die
Verantwortung dafür betrifft wir müssen
als Demokraten
zusammenstehen und es
wird und es wird der großen
Herausforderung nicht gerecht die wir
sehen wenn der rechte Populismus in den
USA so viel Unterstützung bekommt wenn
wir gesehen haben dass er Großbritannien
in ein ökonomisches Unglück gestürzt hat
mit dem brexit und wenn wir sehr klar
sehen dass so viele Regierungen in
Europa von Rechtspopulisten getragen
werden dass sie manchmal dabei sind wir
haben in Deutschland eine Aufgabe für
unser Geschichte wir wollen als
Demokratin und Demokraten zeigen dass
wir diesen Trend stoppen und zwar
gemeinsam und es ist ja alles gesagt das
finde ich gehört doch zur Wahrheit dazu
es ist alles gesagt man soll alle
wörtlich nehmen auch die AFD sie meint
was man ihr unterstellt und zwar das
Schlimme und das ist glaube ich wirklich
die Wahrheit mit der wir uns
auseinandersetzen müssen plötzlich fällt
so ein Wort wie dexit und das ist die
größte
wohlstandsvernichtung die für Europa und
für Deutschland passieren könnte unser
Land hat wie kein anderes profitiert von
der Europäischen Union und der
Zusammenarbeit dort
und deshalb Herr märz kann ich ihn
versichern
Emmanuel macron und ich sind verabredet
sehr sorgfältig
sehr sehr sorgfältig wie wir im einzeln
reagieren auf die möglichen politischen
Entwicklung die in der Welt auf uns
zukommen und auch für alle muss klar
sein wenn die Welt noch schwieriger wird
auch z.B durch das was an Wahlen in den
USA Ergebnis als W Ergebnis möglich ist
dann muss die Europäische Union umso
stärker werden und Frankreich und
Deutschland müssen diese Aufgabe
wahrnehmen dass das auch tatsächlich
möglich
wird und natürlich zählt dazu dass wir
immer im Blick haben dass Europa
stärkste nationale Interesse ist dass
wir haben und das hat dann viele viele
Konsequenzen aber zu denen zählt auch
dass es manchmal nicht gut ist die
Politik eine Zeit lang nicht so
sorgfältig verfolgt zu haben wenn immer
die Beispiele wo es irgendwie noch was
war sehr sehr lange zurückliegen aber
ich finde das ist doch eine gute
Zusammenarbeit war die ich auch mit Frau
Merkel hatte als wir mit der
französischen Regierung gemeinsam dafür
gesorgt haben dass es möglich ist auf
auf die coronakrise zu reagieren mit
einem europäischen wiederaufbaufond die
letzte große europäische Initiative
liegt nicht lange zurück nur ihre
Beteiligung an diesen politischen
Geschehnissen die liegt lange zurück und
ich finde man muss dann auch einmal
stolz sein auf das was eine eigene
Regierungschefin zustande gebracht hat
es war richtig was wir dort gemacht
haben Herr März vergessen Sie es nicht
reden sie nicht drüber hinweg es war
eine CDU Kanzler mit der das gemeinsam
gelungen
ist im übrigen im übrigen sind wir dabei
all das
aufzuarbeiten was in diesem Land liegen
geblieben ist und es ist sehr viel
liegen geblieben über viele Jahre über
sehr sehr sehr viele Jahre sind die
entscheidenden Weichen nicht gestellt
worden damit Deutschland eine
industrielle Zukunft haben kann und
deshalb deshalb Herr März war ihre Frage
berechtigt was hat eigentlich diese Rede
von ihnen mit dem gegenwärtigen Haushalt
und der gegenwerärtigen Lage zu tun
nichts da haben sie recht aber die Frage
muss man
erweitern was hat eigentlich ihr
politisches Programm mit der Zukunft
Deutschlands zu tun nichts das ist die
Antwort die wir darauf geben
müssench wirklich im Untergrundkampf und
intensiv dafür gesorgt haben dass es
keinen Ausbau der Netze in Deutschland
gibt nachdem sie als CDU CSU
Verantwortung dafür haben dass der
Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energie nicht
vorangekommen ist nachdem sie nichts
geschafft haben für die Erschaffung
einer wasserstoffindustrie und Struktur
für Deutschland nachdem sie es nicht
hingekriegt haben dass Investitionen in
der Stahlindustrie in der
Halbleiterindustrie in den
batteriefabriken in Deutschland
stattfinden finden alle diese Dinge
jetzt statt zwei Jahre haben Tempo
gemacht wo Tempo notwendig
war und wenn
wir und wenn wir genau hingehört haben
bei dem was Sie gesagt haben dann haben
sie ja gar nichts gelernt all die
Wachstumsbremsen die sie für Deutschland
gezogen haben die wollen sie
wiederziehen haben sie hier angekündigt
wie kann man so die Zukunft Deutschlands
verspielen wollen wie sie das tun
ökonomischer Sachverstand Null das ist
die Wahrheit keine Perspektive für
Deutschland keine industrielle
Perspektive keine Perspektive für die
Arbeitsplätze und ich will ihn gerne
ergänzen sie reden damit das so klappt
an all dem vorbei was an Wirklichkeit
über Deutschland zu berichten ist
und zu dieser Wirklichkeit gehört in der
Tat dass wir zu kämpfen haben mit
weltweiter Wachstumsschwäche dass wir zu
kämpfen haben mit den Wachstumsbremsen
der Vergangenheit die wir gelöst haben
dass wir aber auch verzeichnen können
Deutschland hat den höchsten
Beschäftigungsstand in der Geschichte
den wir jemals verzeichnet haben noch
nie waren so viele Arbeitnehmer und
Arbeitnehmer
erwerbstätig und wenn
sich
wenn sich die Unternehmen in diesem
Lande vor etwas fürchten dann ist es
nicht wie vor 20 Jahren
Arbeitslosigkeit sondern dann ist es
arbeitskräftangel das ist die
Herausforderung der Zukunft und diese
Regierung hat die Weichen dafür gestellt
dass wir etwas dagegen tun können mit
dem Fachkräfte Einwanderungsgesetz und
mit dem neuen
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht all das ist
eine Perspektive für die Zukunft
Deutschlands
und darum haben wir dafür gesorgt dass
sich Arbeit in Deutschland endlich
wieder
lohnt mit dem Mindestlohn mit einem
Mindestlohn den sie immer wieder
bekämpfen weil wenn sie dafür reden dass
Arbeit sich lohnen l meinen sie 10 20 30
40% unserer Arbeitsbevölkerung die viel
zu wenig verdienen nie mit wir brauchen
bessere Löhne und der Mindestlohn war
genau der Weg das auf einen guten Kurs
zu
bringen und das gleiche Geld für die
Frage der Einkommensverhältnisse
derjenigen die wenig verdienen wir haben
das gemacht mit den Dingen die wir als
Erleichterung für diejenigen die etwas
weniger als 2000 € verdienen gemacht
haben bei den
Sozialversicherungsbeiträgen mit dem
Wohngeld für Erwerbstätige und für
Rentnerinnen und Rentner mit der
Kindergelderhöhung und dem
Kinderzuschlag lauter Maßnahmen die das
Einkommen von Erwerbstätigen die leider
zu geringe Löhne haben verbessern wir
sind stolz auf diese gemeinsame
Leistung und wir haben auch das gehört
dazu mehrfach Steuern gesenkt für
Arbeitnehmer und Arbeitnehmer für
Erwerbstätige die selbstständig sind und
nicht so große Einkommen haben wir haben
Steuern gesenkt und die arbeitende Mitte
dieses Landes entlastet und ich sage ihn
hier diesen Kurs werden wir auch weiter
verfolgen es ist aber gegen die
Zukunftsperspektive der Arbeitnehmer und
Arbeitnehmer gegen diejenigen die jeden
Tag sich anstrengen wenn man ihnen dann
mitteilt dass aller Wichtigste was wir
in Deutschland machen wollen trotz
stabiler rentenfinanzen die wir
gegenwärtig verzeichnen können ist die
Anhebung des
Renteneintrittsalters ergänzt noch durch
schöne laute reden über den Freizeitpark
Deutschland den wir angeblich bei der
großen Beschäftigungszahl die wir heute
haben ich finde diese Verunsicherung der
Lebensperspektive von Arbeitnehmer und
Arbeitnehmern die sie dort verbreiten
ist nicht in Ordnung und ich finde dass
es eine Beleidigung ist von fleißigen
Bürgern und Bürgern wenn man sagt sie
würden in einem Freizeitpark leben das
ist nicht
was soll die altväterliche beschimppfung
von Arbeitnehmern und Arbeitnehmern die
ihren Alltag zu organisieren wollen mit
alle müssen mal mehr arbeiten sie
arbeiten ganz schön viel und ich finde
solche Belehrung haben sich die
fleißigen dieses Landes auch vom
Oppositionsführer nicht
verdient meine Damen und
Herren natürlich natürlich ist es
wichtig dass wir uns den Herausforderung
stellen die wir haben und eine davon ist
dass es angesprochen worden die
irreguläre
Migration und da haben
wir sehr viele sehr weitreichende
Entscheidung getroffen übrigens im
größten Einvernehmen mit den 16 Ländern
dreimal haben wir uns mit ihnen
getroffen im letzten Jahr und haben alle
Fragen abgearbeitet und dreimal
gemeinsame Beschlüsse gefasst ein
endgültiger Finanzierungsmechanismus für
aufsteigende und absteigende zahlen wir
haben ganz konkrete Maßnahmen vereinbart
die der Bund machen muss und er hat sie
alle mit den Gesetzen die wir jetzt in
diesem Januar beschlossen haben
geliefert und auf den Weg gebracht und
wir arbeiten daran dass es auch den
Ländern gelingt die Dinge voranzubringen
die sie übernommen haben kürzere
Asylverfahren schnellere digitalisier
der Ausländerbehörden und so weiter aber
wenn es dann so ist das ganz ohne ihr
Zutun die Länder mit dem Bund
vereinbaren dass wir eine Bezahlkarte
für
Asylbewerber einführen wenn jetzt die
Ausschreibung läuft und der
oppositionspörer liest offenbar nicht
mal Zeitung und kann daraus berichten
dass das der Fall ist und links auf dem
Weg dann ist irgendwas nicht richtig im
Lande der
Opposition
lesen Sie nicht nur wenig Zeitung
sondern reden auch nicht mit den CDU
Ministerpräsidenten die hätten ihn das
so beim Bier mal nebenbei sagen können
das wäre eine gute Sache gewesen
übrigens mit dem intensivierten Schutz
unserer
Außengrenzen mit dem Dingen die wir auf
den Weg gebracht haben gehen die Zahlen
jetzt auch zurück was die irreguläre
Migration betrifft und die Maßnahmen
über die ich eben geredet habe die sind
ja alle jetzt erst beschlossen werden
gerade gesetzt die kommen ja zuem noch
dazu was jetzt auch in der Realität in
nächster Zeit wirken wird und dazu zählt
aus meiner Sicht übrigens auch der jobto
mit dem wir dafür Sorge tragen dass die
ukrainischen Flüchtlinge nachdem sie die
ganzen Sprachkurse gemacht haben jetzt
auch aktiv in den Arbeitsmarkt
vermittelt werden mit wachsendem Erfolg
und ich finde übrigens auch dort ist es
kein Beitrag zur Solidarität mit der
Ukraine wenn der Oppositionsführer den
hier Schutz suchenden Ukrainerinnen und
Ukrain mitteilt dass wir ihm so
entgegengekommen sind war wohl ein
Fehler das haben sie gemacht Herr mer
das haben sie
gemacht aber ich will gerne einen Satz
hinzufügen ich habe ja bei dem einen
großen Thema ich will gleich noch drauf
kommen Tempo Tempo in Deutschland
versucht ein deutschlandpakt zuand
bringen und sie dazu zu bringen
mitzumachen was sie irgendwie nicht
richtig hingekriegt haben aber aber es
ist so dass sie dann sicher auf ein
Teilthema kurzzeitig konzentriert hatten
Migration und wir hatten darüber auch
gute Gespräche jedenfalls Erin ich mich
an keins davon schlecht wir hatten eins
das war sehr
sorgfältig und in diesem Gespräch in
diesem Gespräch habe ich ihn erläutert
dass es schon quasi über viele Fragen
die ganz wichtig sind eine verständig
gibt mit den Chefs der Senats und
staatskanzlein und dass wir am folgenden
Montag wir trafen uns Freitag das wohl
mit den Ministerpräsidentin und
Ministerpräsidenten vereinbaren werden
sie hatten überhaupt nichts dagegen
anzuwenden weil wir nämlich gesagt haben
darüber hinaus können wir ja noch was
machen und was erlebt die erstaunte
Öffentlichkeit kaum ist diese Einigung
mit den Ministerpräsidenten
beschlossen erklärt der erklärt der
Oppositionsführer ja dann war's das wohl
mit der Zusammenarbeit in der Migration
so eine hasenfüßigkeit vor der eigenen
Verantwortung davon laufen das habe ich
noch nicht erlebt Herr MZ so viel
feikeit vor der eigenen Courage habe ich
noch nie gesehen ich R bis heute warum
sie davon gelaufen sind und ich glaube
es lag daran dass sie das schöne Thema
nicht loswerden wollten wir können alles
geliefert haben alles kann ordentlich
gemacht sein wir kriegen das in den
Griff gemeinsam mit den Ländern und den
Kommunen in Deutschland was die
irreguläre Migration und ihr Managment
betrifft aber dann können sie ja nicht
mehr sagen alles läuft schief und darum
sind sie weggelaufen das ist der Grund
warum sie für ein Kompromiss nicht mehr
weiter zur Verfügung stehen
überhaupt sind sie da ein ganz
besonderer Teilen jeden Tag gegen die
Bundesregierung aus ist ihr recht wer
unter die Gürtellinie ist auch ihr Recht
aber wenn sie dann mal kritisiert werden
dann sind sie eine Mimose ich finde wer
ein wer Box der soll kein glaskin haben
aber sie haben ein ganz schönes gask
her meine Damen und
Herren wir haben eine groe eine
angesichts des russischen angriffskriegs
auf die Ukraine und der wird ja jetzt
auch heute Abend in Brüssel nach den
trauerfeierigkeiten für Jacques Delor
und morgen eine große Rolle spielen wir
müssen die Ukraine unterstützen in ihrem
Freiheitskampf um den es in der Tat geht
und es ist notwendig dass wir mit der
Unterstützung der Ukraine nicht
nachlassen das ist unsere Verpflichtung
für den Frieden in Europa und Sicherheit
in
Europa es ist übrigens erstaunliches was
die Ukrainer Ukrainer geleistet haben
vergessen wir nicht wie viel von ihrem
Territorium von Russland schon erobert
war und wie viel sie auch wieder
zurückerobert haben vergessen wir nicht
mit welcher beharlichkeit Sie sich den
unglaublichen Ansturm russischer Truppen
wo der russische Präsident den Verlust
eigener Soldaten nicht scheut in
größeren Orten die man kaum
auszusprechen mag und wo er nicht scheut
Material einzusetzen und alles zerstören
zu lassen um das Ziel das er hat
tatsächlich zu erreichen nämlich ein
Teil oder die ganze Ukraine zu erobern
und er hat damit das in Frage gestellt
was Willie Brand und Helmut Schmidt auf
den Weg gebracht haben mit KSZE und
heutiger OSZE mit der Friedens und
sicherheitsordnung in Europa die lautet
mit Gewalt dürfen keine Grenzen in
Europa mehr verschoben werden das mus
unser Prinzip
sag in der ganzen Welt hat sich
rumgesprochen bald auch in Deutschland
wir sind der größte Unterstützer nach
den USA für die Ukraine auch was
militärische Unterstützung mit Waffen
betrifft und wir sind es mit dem
Haushalt über den wir hier beraten und
den plän für dieses Jahr auch in Europa
nach allem was wir wissen können
es ist mehr als die Hälfte was aus
Deutschland geleistet werden wird in
diesem Jahr für diesen Widerstand der
Ukraine und deshalb sage ich hier an
dieser Stelle ist es mir ganz wichtig
dass wir eine breitere europäische
Unterstützung hinbekommen es kann nicht
alleine an Deutschland hängen um noch
einmal Helmut Schmidt zu zitieren wir
sind nur eine Mittelmacht und wenn wir
diejenigen wären die das überwiegend
machen müssen dann ist es ist nicht
genug für die Ukraine wir wollen dass
mehr Länder sich aktiv beteiligen an der
Unterstützung der Ukraine auch mit
Waffenlieferung auch mit dem was sie
dort
finanzieren ich sage das bewusst
nicht um andere
vorzuführen deshalb haben wir das auch
nicht getan dass wir da einzelne
öffentlich angesprochen haben weil wir
wollen ja das Gegenteil wir wollen ja
das alle sagen okay wir strengen uns
noch einmal an und das hoffe ich wird
auch das Ergebnis der Beratung sein die
wir heute und morgen beginnen aber
sicherlich in dieser Frage nicht
abschließen werden nur das will ich hier
gerne versichern wir werden unseren
großen Beitrag für dieses Jahr leisten
und wir werden alles dafür tun dass der
gemeinsame Beitrag Europas so groß ist
dass die Ukraine darauf bauen kann und
dass Putin nicht darauf rechnen kann
dass unsere Unterstützung irgendwann st
das darf nicht
denken ja ja es ist so der hofft auf die
amerikanischen
Präsidentschaftswahlen der hofftft auf
das ermüden in
Europa und wir wissen wie schwierig das
ist wenn wir in die USA gucken es wird
ist immer noch nicht gelungen dass der
amerikanische Präsident eine Zustimmung
Kongress für seine Haushaltsmittel
bekommen hat die er für die
Unterstützung der Ukraine dieses Jahr
benötigt ich bin ganz zuversichtlich
dass er das schaffen
wird und wir werden alle unseren Beitrag
leisten mitzuhelfen zu überzeugen dass
das eine gemeinsame Sache für uns die
Freunde der Freiheit der Demokratie und
des Rechtsstaats ist die Ukraine nicht
alleine zu
lassen aber man stelle sich einmal kurz
vor das gelingt nicht und dann wäre deut
Deutschland stand jetzt der größte
Unterstützer was Waffenlieferung
betrifft für die Ukraine
weltweit liebe Freundinnen und Freunde
das ist etwas wo wir international alles
dafür tun müssen dass dieser Zustand
nicht eintritt denn es wäre Hybris wenn
wir glaubten dass wir alleine es richten
können so ist es nicht wir brauchen
Gemeinsamkeit und
Solidarität
übrigens gilt das auch für die anderen
Beschlüsse die jetzt in Europa notwendig
sind über den europäischen Haushalt den
wir jetzt endlich beschließen wollen und
ind dem ist ja auch eine Haushaltshilfe
für die Ukraine von 12 Milliarden Euro
pro Jahr für die nächsten Jahre
vorgesehen es geht also um sehr viel
Unterstützung die notwendig ist es geht
um ein zusammenstehen Europas in diesen
Zeiten und das will ich dann auch zum
Schluss im Hinblick auf unser
gemeinsames Europa sagen ja wir brauchen
eine gemeinsame Anstrengung dass Europa
vorankommt und wie ich es vielleicht für
den einen oder anderen überraschend
unbedingt auf einem SPD Parteitag gesagt
habe wir brauchen die Banken und
kapitalmarktunion damit das vorangeht
und deshalb müssen wir aus dem was wir
schon geschafft haben eine weitere
Initiative entfalten die
Mindestbesteuerung die wir etabliert
haben könnte doch auch der Maßstab sein
für eine einheitliche gemeinsame
körperschaftsbasis
basiskörperschaftssteuer damit die
Banken europaweit unter fairen
Bedingungen Wettbewerb machen können das
wäre ein echter Fortschritt für Europa
und wir brauchen ihn dringend wir
brauchen ihn dringend denn tatsächlich
ist ein Teil des besseren
Wirtschaftswachstums der USA
zurückzuführen auf ihre Banken und
Kapitalmärkte die mehr in der Lage sind
das Wachstum der Wirtschaft ohne
öffentliche Subventionen zu begleiten
und groß zu investieren in Startups und
wachsende Unternehmen manchmal welche
die jahrelang trotz Milliarden Bewertung
keine Gewinne machen das ist etwas was
in Europa in gleicher Weise nicht
vorkommt und deshalb ist es unsere
gemeinsame Aufgabe dass wir diesen
dieses Hindernis für Wachstum und
Wohlstand in Europa beseitigen und die
Tatsache dass es dieses Jahr so viel um
Europa gehen muss die ist vielleicht ein
Anlass an diesem und allen anderen
notwendigen Reform für ein starkes
souveränes Europa in einer
globalisierten Welt zu arbeiten schönen
Dank